just feel like you are a great person to
talk to
about this you are emancipated at 17.
kind of watching what britney spears has
been going through with her
conservatorship what has that been like
i guess
for you and is there anything that you
would say on the situation
i support brittany i think britney's
incredible um her story is incredibly
moving
i listen to her testimony i think she is
so smart
so capable um she should absolutely be
free to live her life be in control of
her life in control of herself i think
it's absurd
um that this is the situation that she
has to be in i
think you know the justice system
unfortunately is
um is corrupt i think it's just an
absurd situation
i feel for her i hope she gets to be in
control of her life her situation
um everything um as soon as possible
and i i truly hope the people who have
kept her away from doing that
um do suffer some sort of consequences
because she deserves you know all the
happiness the freedom the love and the
um control of her life that you know she
should have
so amen do you think that britney would
have benefited from
when she was 17 being emancipated from
her family like do you think more child
stars
should look at that as an option i mean
it truly depends
it's it's really for everyone's
situation it's hard to speak on anyone
else's situation
and i you know i wish that she would
have been able to
be free from her situation sooner i i
can't say obviously i think it would
have
benefited her but it was a different
time i hope that things
do change um and get better for her yeah
as soon as possible that's really all i
can say i love that well
you've come out on top and feel like you
have such an amazing
career i feel like you're so genuine
candid on social media
how has the past i guess year and a half
during this pandemic
been on you yeah i mean definitely you
know my my i am
very fortunate i'm blessed in so many
ways um
but i think that's part of the issue on
social media is that everyone's life
looks so positive
i'm doing quite well but um just like
everyone the pandemic was hard
for some harder than others it was it's
devastating to see the effect
it's had um on a lot of people
especially
mental health-wise for me i'm very
fortunate i've been in therapy
uh twice a week for eight years um it's
the best part of my week
um i'm on medication i think it's
important to fully
normalize mental health and the use of
um mental health medications um
so i've tried to uh share that with my
followers
i i don't particularly like the fame
aspect of the industry like i don't you
know i don't like getting my picture
taken when i
didn't consent to getting my picture
taken and i don't really like i like to
have a bit of a private life so i try to
keep that as well but
um i you know i do want people to know
that life is difficult for everyone
in general yeah i go to therapy i've
been on medication for years like it's
great
it's been really helpful for me or the
process is really hard or whatever like
you know i started trauma therapy during
um uh covet and and
that's been really difficult but i see
you know the positive at the end of the
tunnel for it
i i am happy i am very fortunate but i
do also want people to know that
um you know anybody can suffer from
something that is
uh i mean so so so normal
so common like i i encourage everyone to
go to therapy regardless of if it's
you know if they maybe in their minds
haven't experienced anything traumatic
or whatever like
go to therapy therapy is important um
like i said it's honestly the best part
of my week
my journey has benefited me um my
medications have benefited me they've
definitely been
it's just in general i feel like it's
it's a disservice to
to not share that with people and if you
know people
want to judge somebody else for
bettering themselves then it's probably
because they're
they're a bit jealous that they don't
have the courage to better themselves
well let's talk about this new venture
rl stein story club
for those who haven't had a chance to
listen quite yet
how would you describe it kind of
explain what it is
um goku go is a podcast network for
children
uh that created a first of its kind
avengers like universe
of repeating characters and storylines
basically kids can
listen to a variety of podcasts that are
engaging and creative and
fun for everyone which i love because
during covet i feel like
kids need to be listening to podcasts
more than they're playing games on
per se and ipad how has the reception
kind of been
uh it's honestly been great uh it's only
been out for a few weeks but uh
we have several thousand subscribers uh
growing every day yeah so anyone who's
watching this
please subscribe to our sign story club
um
free on apple podcast spotify
everyone else podcasts are
[Music]
[Music]
you